hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about type 5
hypersensitivities um before we get
started i want to remind you that you
can get free study notes by going to the
tiny url you see in the description
below that is going to include
a pdf a free pdf of the final board with
all the notes on it so be sure you check
that out for study purposes and remember
to subscribe so let's go ahead and get
started so type five remember that v
right there is the roman numeral five so
type five hypersensitivity and you might
already be thinking hey whoa stop what
because there's only four types of
hypersensitivity right well
most of the time that's what we see
and it's actually a little difficult to
find information on type 5
hypersensitivities
and that's because
what some people classify as a type 5
hypersensitivity
is actually generally classified in most
um
in most resources
as just a subset of type 2
hypersensitivity
and so that's why if you go and look at
say the wikipedia page or
various textbooks you there's a good
chance you're just going to see four
types of hypersensitivities listed but
i'm going to use this video to tell you
the distinction between type 5 and type
2 and why
some experts do have type 5 as like a
hypersensitivity classification on its
own
but really quick let's just review what
the type 2 hypersensitivity is that is
where you have antibodies remember
another name for antibodies is
immunoglobulins
so you have igg that's immunoglobulin g
or igm that's immunoglobulin
m so igg or ign these are antibodies
attack cellular surface antigens so this
is just some antigenic component on the
surface of a cell
and this leads to some kind of cellular
damage or outright cellular destruction
so that's the hallmark of the type 2
hypersensitivity
and so this is known
for its cytotoxic
or cytotoxicity effects where it is
toxic meaning damage or destruction to
the cell remember prefix cyto means cell
so
what is type 5
type 5 hypersensitivity is when you have
one of those same types of antibodies
idt or ign
target fm not
simply any surface antigen
but target
a hormone
receptor
on a hormone producing cell
so whereas type 2 is looking at really
any type of cell
and antibodies attacking any surface
antigen type 5 is more specific we're
looking at hormone producing cells and
specifically these antibodies targeting
a hormone receptor
on that hormone-producing cell
now an example of this is graves disease
so this is where antibodies will
stimulate the actual receptor that's
their target they will they will
stimulate the thyroid stimulating
hormone receptor
leading to
an over
active
thyroid
now if you go to most textbooks or
wikipedia for example you'll actually
see gray's disease given as an example
of a type 2 hypersensitivity so i want
you to be aware of that if you see it in
both places
but in some situations i think it's a
little bit more prevalent like over in
great britain
um you might see type 5 being not a
subset of type 2 but being its own
classification of hypersensitivity
um i also want to point out one more
thing you know whereas type 2 is
associated with this cytotoxic effect
certainly an overactive thyroid is not a
good thing but it's not necessarily
resulting in a lot of cellular
destruction which is another reason why
this might be set aside as a separate
type of hypersensitivity now i have
another very popular video where i
review all four of those classical types
of hypersensitivities so type one type
twos and three type four comparing and
contrasting them so make sure you check
that one out and then we've talked about
antibodies a lot in this video these igg
and ign antibodies so if you want to
learn a little bit more about antibodies
and their structure and their function
then i've also got a video on that make
sure you remember to subscribe check out
that link below for free study
notes for a picture of the final board
and pdf form and i will see you next
time good luck with your studying and
bye for now